I was watching this program called who
do you think you are yes and there was
this beautifully unintentionally
hilarious moment where they got one of
these celebrities uh I I can't remember
who it was a black lady and they were
talking about her ancestor who was a
slave obviously she was very upset by
this understandably so and then she went
well this slave won her won his freedom
she was like oh marvelous that's so good
and then they went and then he went on
to own slaves and she was absolutely
mortified
Jamaica Jamaica SS a return of slaves
in the Parish of Manchester
in the possession in The Possession
James Gordon Harriet as owner
on the 20th 28th day of June
in the year of Our Lord
1825 oh my word
yeah
he owned
one two three four five six seven eight
slips
actually
my great old grandson was a slave
wow
I don't know what to say all right this
is uh
this is just quite amazing that one
moment you're feeling this almost hatred
for people who
dominated and controlled and
times abused
my three times great mother Catherine
Smith
I'm getting so angry with being in that
church up in Manchester and looking at
that plaque
John Davey and yet
my own grandfather
and only twice removed was a
slave owner himself yes
sorry
didn't expect this at all
it was all it was funny in a way because
it was like
it's not simple yeah and this idea that
we're presented with and this
this how can I put it that's it yeah
reductive view of History yeah of course
yeah it's it's nonsensical yeah yeah and
I think that kind of view of history as
well also explains why there is this
view that there is some sort of
universal black identity that black
people around the world all share the
same values and the same beliefs and the
same Outlook and this is completely
wrong from my own particular experience
as well so as I said at the at the very
start I was born in Nigeria
um and in Nigeria over 99 of the
population is black so you say you don't
have diversity
have they not been told diversity is
their strength not where should I myself
other types of diversity so the um so of
course race is not at the Forefront yeah
of the minds of the ordinary Nigerian
um and race is not one of the factors
that
um defied Society
um other factors such as ethnic tribal
group religion
um region or geography those are the
things that shape the Visions within
Nigerian Society
um and and this this became
evidence to me when um last year
um my brother was getting married and my
brother lives in America and he was
getting married to an African-American
woman so a woman was ancestors uh more
enslaved Africans and she brought along
um a lot of her family members and
friends to Nigeria and I and I assume
that many of these black Americans
expected a kind of homecoming a kind of
Return of the prodigal son or daughter
or whatever
um but the Striking thing is that
what struck many of these Nigerians was
not the fact that these black Americans
were black it was the fact that these
black Americans were Americans so the
americanness of them was the most
striking thing to the Nigerians
um which I think just goes to illustrate
that
race is not at the Forefront of the
minds of many African people themselves
other things might shape the way that
they look at Black Americans black
British people and black people from
across the rest of the world so what
you're saying is and it's very
controversial is that people's skin
color doesn't determine how they act and
behave and think that's I mean that's
incredible man such a radical point it's
a radical idea
thank you